[MUSIC PLAYING]
GARNETTE CADOGAN:
Many times, what
is happening, at
the heart of racism,
are people not merely denying
other people's dignity
and humanity, but denying their
very own dignity and humanity.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH HANSEN: Today
on Chalk Radio,
an innovative approach to
teaching about race and racism.
GARNETTE CADOGAN: It means
pulling back and asking
some tough questions
about our society,
about ourselves, about what
it takes to move forward,
understanding each
other, but also
working to advance a much
more just society and a much
better way of understanding
what it means to coexist.
SARAH HANSEN: In this episode,
an urban studies course
examines our lives
in public spaces
and invites us to consider how
our very personal experiences
might also contain the
experiences of others.
In our conversation about his
course 11.S947 "The Fire This
Time--
Race and Racism in American
Cities", visiting scholar
and acclaimed essayist
Garnette Cadogan
shares his approach for
helping students wrestle with,
as he puts it, the story of
racism in the United States.
Part of what I love
about Garnette's approach
is how he weaves his own life
experiences into his teaching.
A large focus of
his life and work
has been observing cities
through a unique modality--
walking.
GARNETTE CADOGAN: It's
such a human pace.
It allows us to inscribe
ourselves onto the world
and allows the world to inscribe
itself onto our imagination.
But, more than
anything else, it's
a marvelously joyful
way of getting
to know the world, of
getting to know it up close,
not merely getting to
know it but getting
to know ourselves through
the surprising encounters we
might have.
So one of the things I
love most about walking
is the way in which it
opens us up to serendipity.
So walking as a way
of knowing the world,
as a way of knowing
ourselves, as a way of being
open to the surprise and
serendipities of the world.
SARAH HANSEN: Garnette
grew up in Jamaica,
where he learned to navigate
public spaces on foot.
GARNETTE CADOGAN: In
Jamaica, as I walked,
I walked a lot at night
after public transportation
had stopped running and would
navigate from friends' homes
to my home and pass through some
very dangerous neighborhoods
and learned how to be streetwise
as in the wisdom gained
from constant observation
and being able to anticipate
dangers or sometimes
encountering true dangers
and knowing how to get
away from the dangers.
And I thought that's
all you needed
to do to be navigating in
public space and to be safe,
to anticipate the dangers
and veer away from them.
SARAH HANSEN: When he
arrived in the United States
as a college student, his
experiences with racism
began to shape the way he
traversed city streets.
GARNETTE CADOGAN: And I came
to the US with that sensibility
and then began encountering
racism but recognized that what
actually happened then,
it wasn't so much learning
how to read the
danger but learning
to read the places in which
people thought I was a danger.
That's what had happened that--
and it was over and over again
me seeing the dangers
and veering away from it
but then suddenly
recognizing and being shocked
to know that I was the danger.
And I was a danger
because I was Black,
because of my skin color.
So navigating then
suddenly became
trying to anticipate the ways
in which people would anticipate
me being dangerous.
It meant calibrating my
movements not to fear
but calibrating my movements
to people's fear of me
and knowing that that
could be dangerous to me,
that it could mean anything
from them attacking me, which
had happened, or
threatening to attack
me or them calling the
police, who would then
give me a tough time.
I'm able to many times
deal with awfulness
that the world throws at
me because of the beauty
that the world also presents,
that the world is never
just one thing.
And so, yes, there
are people who
will shout awful racist
things at me in the street.
But there's also that
stranger who says, oh, I'm
going to a barbecue.
And it looks like you're
just wandering and looking
for something to do.
You want to come along with us?
And so that's the
very same world.
SARAH HANSEN: The
There was something so
powerful in that idea.
And I began to wonder how
this outlook shaped Garnette's
teaching in the classroom,
how he approached
the ideas of race and
racism with students
with this outlook in mind.
GARNETTE CADOGAN: I focus very
much in the classroom on joy,
in the way in which joy becomes,
in so many ways, both a hope
and the way joy's wed to hope.
But joy's also
wed to resistance.
In the way joy is
wed to our ability
to deal with these things and
to push past these things.
So, as a teacher,
I, time and again,
try to invite students
to read the way I walk.
It becomes a way of having a
conversation, a conversation
with the past, a conversation
with the present,
a conversation
with people nearby,
a conversation with
people who are far away,
and, more than anything else,
a conversation with yourself,
a way of wrestling
with yourself.
In the end, that's my hope,
a different self can emerge.
A different, better
self, much more open
to discovery and encounter.
SARAH HANSEN: For Garnette,
encountering others
is key to understanding
the story of racism
in American cities and for
imagining a different, much
more dignified way to coexist.
It's an idea that
grounds how he teaches
about these complexities.
GARNETTE CADOGAN: What does it
mean to think of the classroom
as a place of encounter in which
you're continually encountering
these issues, these
histories, these landscapes,
these complexities,
these people?
And what does it mean to truly
listen, to truly understand?
SARAH HANSEN: Garnette
shared with me
that it can feel disheartening
to unpack the complexities
of racism in our society.
Students and teachers alike
may experience burnout
over the course of a semester.
As I talked with
Garnette, it struck me
that helping students cultivate
curiosity about themselves
and others was a strategic way
to sustain their engagement.
GARNETTE CADOGAN: When you
have something so huge,
it's to say, oh, we're
just going to climb
this mountain right away.
It's just impossible.
That your legs will
give out quite quickly.
And it will just
lead to frustration.
So I invite them to
just take a small patch
and to keep moving patch
by patch on that mountain
until, at a certain point,
they'll look up and go,
oh, we're halfway up.
And we're actually
not even trying
to conquer the mountain anymore.
That was the wrong
way to go about it.
We're just now at the
place in which we're
happy to investigate
the terrain and then
to ask each other
what the terrain looks
like where you are so you could
learn more about the mountain.
And we might not actually
even reach the top,
but we'll have a much better
understanding of landscape
and of flora and
fauna and of nature
and a much better sense of what
it means to hike thoughtfully.
SARAH HANSEN: As an
essayist, Garnette
brings an innovative slant to
teaching about race and racism.
For him, the act of writing
and having students write
is a way to do the work
of encountering others.
GARNETTE CADOGAN:
Writing is sometimes
just merely a way of raising
questions rather than giving
answers, particularly on
issues connected with race
and racism in cities.
That's a big order.
It's a lifetime of
thinking and wrestling
with complicated
issues, racism, race,
which is produced by
racism, in American cities.
What does it take to understand
and to wrestle with in a full--
in a scope and the complications
connected with each of these.
And the writing becomes a
way sometimes just merely
to ask questions that
say, oh, we have not been
asking the right questions.
This invites us to
ask new questions.
Or this invites us
to see in new ways.
This invites us to listen.
And, more than
anything, it invites
us to encounter each
other in conversation
but also encounter
others on the page.
It means pulling back and
asking some tough questions
about our society, about
ourselves, about what it takes
to move forward,
understanding each other
but also working to advance
a much more just society
and a much better way of
understanding what it means
to coexist, what it
means to live together
alongside each other.
And the writing becomes
a way to explore that.
So, as they're writing,
they're suddenly
recognizing that the whole
world is their material.
And they're invited to
think just expansively
and to start recognizing the
ways in which they haven't
been seeing, the ways in which
they haven't been looking.
They're beginning to
ask, what might it
mean to listen to the
people who are doing harm,
listen to the people who
have experienced harm,
and to listen more
fully and broadly?
SARAH HANSEN: As my conversation
with Garnette continued,
it became clear that, for
him, listening more fully
means tuning into
how people navigate
the world in nuanced ways.
It means writing about
how they encounter harm
but also how they cultivate
joy and hope and community.
GARNETTE CADOGAN:
There's a temptation
to write about people who
have experienced racism
as just the sum total of
what has happened to them.
So they're merely
victims with no agency.
And they're then invited to go
beyond that by suddenly asking,
what are the ways in
which they experience joy?
What are the ways
in which they hope?
in which they work
towards creating a
sense of belonging
for themselves and others?
What are the tight bonds
of community and family
and country for the people
that we're writing about?
And what are the ways
in which these are
broken or erupted or eroded?
And you're not suddenly
speaking of people
in a condescending or
paternalistic matter.
You're speaking of people
that's fully rounded,
no longer flattened.
But you're seeing them in rich
dimension with aspirations
and joys and frustrations
and faults and virtues.
SARAH HANSEN: Even when
writing about people
as fully rounded
individuals, students
may encounter challenges when
learning to write about race.
Garnette elaborated on one of
the complexities many writers
face.
GARNETTE CADOGAN:
One of the problems
with speaking about
and writing about race
is that too often
people are made
to feel that their
responsibilities are
to explain one side
to another side,
to explain that Black experience
to people who are not Black,
or to explain what it means
to inhabit a particular body
and set of experiences
that are unique to you
and that make moving through
or living in the world
a much worse experience than
someone with a different skin
color.
But part of the challenge is to
show the ways in which racism
degrades everyone, that,
in degrading someone else,
you can't help but
degrade yourself.
And, in that class,
one of the things
I'm trying to
invite people to do,
trying to invite
students to think about,
is the responsibility's
not merely
to think of writing about
race or understanding race,
of trying to show one
set of experiences
to someone who's foreign
to it, but to show
the ways in which we have quite
a bit of common experiences
and that, many times,
what is happening
at the heart of
racism are people
not merely denying other
people's dignity and humanity,
but denying their very
own dignity and humanity.
And so it's an
invitation to figure out
how to write about race
and racism in which we're
showing the ways in which
we contain each other.
So I keep giving them multiple
small exercises in which,
time and time again, they
begin with themselves.
And they begin by
saying, how do I see?
Or even to write that I
want them to just think
about multiple voices.
What does it mean to think
of writing as not just merely
speaking, but as a way
of integrating your voice
with the voice of others?
What are other people's ways
of telling your stories?
And how can you tell a story
about them, your honest telling
of their story, but in
a way that fully honors
them telling their own story.
And that seems like such
a huge task for people.
And so I begin by saying, oh,
let's play critical karaoke.
SARAH HANSEN: Garnette
adapted this practice
from a music
conference he attended
where attendees got
to speak about a song
as the song played.
I sat in on one of his classes
and observed critical karaoke
in action.
It was one of the most
powerful teaching methods
I've seen yet for capturing
how we contain each other.
GARNETTE CADOGAN: They
begin by starting to say,
this is what the song is about.
Or this is why it relates
to this particular issue.
Or my thinking on this issue.
And you're hearing them
speak about the song
but tying the song
to a larger issue
that they're thinking
about and then
speaking about lyrics
of the song or something
that the song does.
And, at that point,
their voice fades out.
And you hear the
song, the song's notes
or the song's lyrics coming.
And it teaches them
in a fun way how
to begin to think
about interweaving
my voice with the
voice of others, how
to speak alongside others
rather than about others
in which you're
speaking about them
denies them agency and dignity.
SARAH HANSEN: Critical
karaoke is one example
of how Garnette is rethinking
how we engage students
in learning about racism.
But there's something
even more profound
at work in his teaching.
He's fundamentally
reimagining a framework
for how we approach the
topic with students,
veering off a well-trod
sequential strategy
and jumping into a mind-opening
matrix of connections.
GARNETTE CADOGAN: I'd looked
at a lot of syllabuses.
I went online and tried to find
every syllabus I could find
that was available at different
universities about race
and racism in
America, particularly
in American cities.
And the approach tends to
have it organized by issue.
This week, we will
discuss slavery.
Or these weeks, we will discuss
slavery, then emancipation,
the Civil Rights Movement,
mass incarceration, policing,
education, environmental
injustice, housing
and development, education.
And I found what
actually happened
was that, when I began
discussing by way of issues,
then people so often
organize around issues.
And then they felt that they had
to resolve it at that moment.
SARAH HANSEN: So he
decided to shift the focus.
GARNETTE CADOGAN: It became on
inequality, on freedom, on joy,
on pessimism and hope, on
belonging, on mythology,
on unrest, on violence, on
resistance, on imagination.
It was an invitation to
say we will not figure out
mass incarceration
in one week, that it
became a way of
spreading the issues out.
And so mass incarceration
would come up
when we were talking
about inequality.
And then it would return
again when we were talking
about hope and pessimism.
And then it would
return again when we
were talking about resistance.
And they then had the invitation
to have spent a whole semester
to think through this thing
and then suddenly recognize
the ways in which we
thought we were all bound up
in each other, the issues
themselves were all bound up
in each other.
As you began to think
about issues having
to do with mass
incarceration, you
were also thinking about issues
having to do with police.
And you were
thinking about issues
having to do with housing.
You were thinking
about education.
You were thinking about
investment and disinvestment.
And suddenly, instead
of in a teleogical line,
which is so often how
we talk about race
and what I recognized with
a lot of the syllabuses,
it's moving from
unfreedom to freedom
with occasional hiccups.
That was the wrong
way to think about it,
rather than a matrix in which
everything was deeply connected
to the other.
SARAH HANSEN:
Garnette views the act
of creating his syllabus as
being very similar to writing
the narrative of a story.
GARNETTE CADOGAN: One thing
I do with the syllabus is
that I make the syllabus
a story in and of itself,
that too often syllabuses are
schematic, that they're almost
disconnected rooms in a house,
or they're treated like rooms
in this mansion, that
there's a site where you
can go from one to the other.
And I think of the
syllabus as one big hall.
And then in a big hall
where different gatherings,
you can go and then
you can come back.
So you don't leave one
room, and you never return.
And so I treat the
syllabus like a full story.
And so there are
songs we will hear.
And then we hear
them again later
on in a different context.
There are poems
that we will read,
and we read them again later on.
Or there's one
particular article
they'll read on the second
week, and then we read it again
on the seventh week,
which seems like, what?
Didn't we read this again?
And they suddenly
read it with new eyes.
And it becomes a way of
seeing it as a story.
And then I think of
things as leitmotifs
to say we will begin
discussing this.
But then we will stop here.
And so they get the taste of it.
And then it comes back
more full-blown later on.
And so I think of it as a
particular narrative arc,
so treat the semester
itself like a narrative arc.
SARAH HANSEN: For
Garnette, the syllabus
must be as multidimensional
as the students themselves,
incorporating opportunities
for joy and reflection.
And it should also be shaped
by the students' voices.
GARNETTE CADOGAN: Every week,
they encounter stand-up comedy.
And they encounter poetry.
They encounter song.
They encounter film.
They encounter short story,
fiction, essay, reportage,
the academic article.
And so there are a
variety of voices.
And it's an invitation
to understand the world
in the many ways the
world presents itself
to you, in knowledge.
One of the fascinating things
about teaching a course
like this is, how
do you keep yourself
open to being taught
by the students?
And thinking about this
balancing of many voices,
voices from the past
or voices near and far.
Can you accommodate
their voices?
And so, in a class
like this, one
has to be very open and
ready to listen and to have
students express their own
autonomy in shaping it.
Because there's also great
irony in not doing that
because one of the things
at the heart of racism
is the denial of
autonomy to others,
the ways in which many
times authorities used
to stamp on autonomy.
And for me not to
listen, not to have
them be active agents in
shaping and reshaping the class
would then be a version of that,
of authority denying autonomy.
SARAH HANSEN: To close,
I'd like to leave you
with a quote from Garnette
about joy and resilience.
GARNETTE CADOGAN:
One of the things
I had made a decision very
early is that I am not the sum
total of what happens to me.
It's just something I
keep reminding students
as they study about
race and racism,
that people are
more than the sum
total of the awful things
that have happened to them,
that there's a possibility
of joy, of resistance,
of moving through the world, not
ignoring the awful things that
have happened to you but of
determining that you will not
let these awful things
define and constrain you.
SARAH HANSEN: If you're
ready to learn more
about writing and teaching
about race and racism
and unpacking the story
of the American city,
you'll soon be able to find
Garnette Cadogan's teaching
materials on our MIT
OpenCourseWare website.
Our materials are always free.
If you're an
educator who remixes
the resources in
your own teaching,
please call or write to
us to share your story.
You'll help inspire others.
Thank you so much for listening.
Signing off from
Cambridge, Massachusetts,
I'm Sarah Hansen from
MIT OpenCourseWare.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
AUDIO BUMPER: Ma, park the car.